all right black holes yeah so you don't
have a chat about how supermassive black
holes grow yes which is what i've been
up to basically is figuring that out
so let me tell you what i think happens
okay go ahead don't they just sit in the
middle of galaxies and just just nibble
up anything that comes too close that
can happen they do just sort of get gas
funneled to them
in the galaxy the thing is
there are very massive supermassive
black holes in the universe and also we
see them at incredible distances so ie
very early on in the universe and there
is a limit to how fast black holes can
grow
just by what we say accreting material
it's sort of like how when you pull the
the plug hole out of the sink all the
water doesn't immediately go down right
there is some pressure that stops all of
the water just forcing itself down like
a bottleneck right you have a bottleneck
around a black hole essentially as well
but it'll all get there eventually it'll
all get there eventually yeah but
there's a certain limit to how fast that
can happen so for example we see
supermassive black holes as early on as
800 million years into the universe's
lifetime unfortunately it's not enough
time to build a black hole in that way
in the early universe you see a black
hole that say a billion times the mass
of the sun right if you think it's had
800 million years to grow that big the
rate that it will be limited to that's
physically not enough time for it to go
living and then you've also got things
in the universe today things like messi
87's black hole that's you know
tens of billions of times the mass of
the sun is huge right and so people
think well how did it get that big now
the one correlation that we see is that
the mass of that black hole is
correlated with how big the galaxy is so
it's like the two have grown up together
essentially right so if you add more
mass to the galaxy you add more mass to
the black hole but there's also a link
between the size of the black hole
and the middle part of a galaxy so if
you picture a galaxy it's got that sort
of disc shape and then it's got this
central bulge and it's even more tightly
correlated with the mass of that central
bulge now where those bulges come from
is from mergers so two galaxies merge
together and you'd redistribute all the
annual momentum and the energy in that
galaxy that kept all those stars on nice
sort of circular orbits that we see you
can take it so those stars are basically
sank towards the center and instead of
on you know nice ordered orbits they're
on sort of like chaotic orbits like a
beehive but you can imagine that in a
merger when stuff obviously then does
sink to the center in this
redistribution of energy
then that material will also feed the
black hole and you'll also get the two
black holes merging together are you
saying the reason supermassive black
holes can grow bigger than they should
is because of mergers and they gobble up
a whole other black hole yeah because i
would have thought with the bathtub with
the water going down yeah if i suddenly
came along with another bathtub full of
water and just poured it on top water in
it still wouldn't be able to get down
that hole any quicker you're not dumping
the other black hole onto what we call
the accretion disk which is sort of the
bathtub of water that's trying to spiral
in you've almost merged the two plug
holes so you've made the plug hole
bigger so not only have you grown the
black coil in that way you've then
almost made it easier for it to create
more material right because you've made
it so that it has a bigger gravitational
pull and it can take more in so this is
why people think those are so tightly
correlated is because you get the merger
and you get extra growth from it and
then you see that in the fact that the
bigger that bulge gets the bigger your
black hole gets as well so much that by
the time you get to galaxies that are
all bulged you know these elliptical
galaxies that are perfect steroids that
have had all of that nice rotation
destroyed in lots and lots of mergers
over their lifetime they tend to have
the biggest black holes and so for a
long time people were like that's how
blacks holes grow they grow emerges look
at this correlation
anything that doesn't have a bulge or
has a very small bulge
has piddly black holes right because
that because it hasn't had any mergers
exactly and because all it was able to
grow with was your way you said at the
start which was just sort of happily
taking in whatever was around it and the
work that we did first of all in my
thesis and i've
followed up in the past couple years as
well
was we took the galaxies that don't have
a bulge
and we said let's look at what mass
those black holes actually are
now you might have thought well that
would have been a really obvious thing
to do but they're very very rare these
galaxies we first of all had to wait
until there was a huge catalogue of all
the shapes of galaxies out there that we
could use which came with a
classification site called galaxy zoo
which hopefully some of your viewers
will recognize it was the website that
got people to classify the shapes it's
still going still needs help if people
are up for it and with that sort of
database you know in a million galaxies
we could start with to look at
we ended up with a hundred of them
of these things that didn't have bulges
so that just shows how rare they are
there are also things with growing black
holes as well so the way you get at the
mass and you actually measure the mass
of the black hole is you measure how
fast the material that's spiraling
around it is going which means it has to
be actively growing for us to be able to
spot them so when that happens that
material starts to glow this is what we
call like a quasar when it's like
glowing very very brightly right it
sometimes goes in the x-ray but also it
can glow in the optical and so when that
happens you also get emission from
hydrogen gas and so you've got the sort
of radiation coming from this material
that then impacts the atoms in hydrogen
it excites the electrons so if you
remember chemistry from gcses you have
your electrons in your orbits they jump
up one and then when they drop back down
they emit a very specific color or
wavelength of light and so if you were
to take a spectrum of that
gas that's orbiting around that galaxy
where you split the light you would
hopefully see this giant peak at that
hydrogen color or wavelength what you
see though is instead of it being a very
specific wavelength it's sort of smeared
out and that's because half of the gas
is coming towards you
so it's blue shifted and half of it's
moving away from you so it's red shifted
so if you can imagine how far that gas
has been sort of smeared out you can
measure how big the black hole is
because we know how fast the thing is
moving you know how big the thing is
moving around which blew my mind as a
phd student being like oh look from this
line that does this i can tell you how
big this super massive black hole is
this seems like a lot of room for error
in this process but yeah
but it's still possible so we looked at
these things and we found that
they obviously didn't lie on this
correlation of black hole mass and bulge
mass if this is the line where this is
everything nicely sits here's the most
massive things the most massive bulges
and the most massive black holes all our
bald list things were over here so these
are galaxies that haven't had mergers
that have somehow grown their black hole
just as big without merging with any
other black holes
how to do it exactly so this is what
we're now trying to figure out right is
that yeah okay we go back to this idea
of okay black holes can accrete material
that's around them
but it's limited to how fast it can do
that fine but how does it first of all
get there
so the galaxies we're looking at with
these borders things they're very pure
sort of spiral galaxies they've been
left alone their entire lives right so a
lot of them have beautiful spiral arms
there some of them have these bar
structures in as well and so the leading
hypothesis is that they funnel gas in
and they funnel stuff to the center now
all the work that's been done looking at
the limit of the black hole is obviously
done in other galaxies and not in this
so there are some ideas that that could
be different possibly and that could be
affected by the properties of the black
hole the paper i had last year was
trying to work out what rate that
material is being flowed in at basically
and whether that will affect things
slightly so we looked at a smaller
number of these galaxies looked about 10
of them i somehow managed to call them
after harry potter characters in the
paper i got that past the referee and i
was very very pleased with myself it was
all about what color i'd highlighted
them on the page like to observe that
night it was like the red ones had to be
observed on tuesday night so they were
all named after gryffindor's the green
ones on wednesday nights it was
slytherin when we looked at these
galaxies what we found was that um
their accretion rates of the black hole
the amount of material these black holes
were taking in
were five times higher than in a
sample of galaxies that had undergone
these mergers but the crucial thing was
is that unlike a bathtub where all the
water goes down the plughole can you
imagine if you took out the plug hole
and the pressure around it built up so
much from that bottleneck that it threw
water back out at you this is what black
holes do right i like to say that they
burp essentially they're trying to take
in so much at once that the easiest
thing to do is that pressure builds up
and builds up is to throw some material
back out it doesn't come from the black
hole and that's what confuses a lot of
people it happens before the material
you know reaches that event horizon that
point of no return what we found is that
in galaxies that have had these huge
mergers you reach that pressure point
sooner
and so actually you have these the burp
point exactly so these galaxies that
have mergers are actually burping up
five times more than our galaxies that
haven't so our galaxies that haven't are
still burping a little bit they're just
not doing a giant megafit they're
actually taking in more material than
the ones that have had mergers so the
ones that have had mergers are just
throwing most of it back out again so
it's almost like if you've had a merger
the black hole's a bit more full and
doesn't want to aid as much exactly yeah
it's already merged with another one
it's like i'm
done and the galaxy's like but it is
worth a thin and then you end up with
this huge book but the thing is what
also happens is that um the faster a
black hole itself spins
the more efficient it is at accretion
and that it can push up that limit
so and this is very this is a very
important thing that we concluded in
this paper was that if you think about
how the black hole is actually getting
this material
in a galaxy that hasn't had a merger
that's been left alone has its nice pure
disc it's all coming in from the same
angle and so it's always going to spin
up and spin up and spin up the black
hole whereas in a merger of two galaxies
that funnels stuff towards the center
and sinks up to the center that's going
to be coming from all different
directions
and so wasp wasp
sorry could you be more english
bees yes no
but in a merger where you've had two
galaxies merged together and all that
material is coming from all sorts of
different directions then that black
hole is going to be getting some
material from this direction which will
spin it up this way but then some
material from this direction which will
spin it back the opposite way and so
what we found was that the sort of
average thing that was probably
happening is that in merger galaxies the
black hole is being spun down as we call
it it's being averaged back to zero
whereas in our bulgeless galaxies it's
being spun up all the time and it's
secretions getting more efficient and
that's what allows them to grow so big
because it's sort of like the sort of
slow and steady tortoise rather than
sort of the greedy hair in a way i
didn't know material from outside a
black hole could spin up the black hole
that way i thought once it crossed the
event horizon like all information is
lost it inherits the angular momentum of
the material that falls in which is
quite cool these results that we had
were done with what's called narrowband
imaging so instead of taking a spectrum
of light where you get sort of the
emission from one specific element
instead what you do is you say okay
given the redshift of that galaxy i know
this element's emission will be around
about this wavelength and so i'm only
going to let in light from that specific
wavelength and take an image in that
narrow strip and then from that you can
sort of then work out well how much
energy is in that because all of these
burps they tend to be very energetic and
they will um
excite these electrons but in oxygen in
the galaxy right so if we can just
observe oxygen then we can just get you
know what's going on in that burp but
again what you need is this data where
instead of just taking one spectrum
either from the very center of the
galaxy you can split it into a jigsaw
and take lots and lots and lots of them
so you not only can find out where this
sort of burp emission is and therefore
work out how much there is of it you can
also figure out what impact it's having
on the galaxy around it as well because
that kind of throwing back out of energy
back into the galaxy can then have a
huge effect on the galaxy itself right
it can heat gas up that you need to make
stars it can expel gas from a galaxy so
there's huge repercussions so it's
really important to understand how this
tiny little process can have this huge
impact everywhere else and what's
interesting to me is that like okay yes
mergers were almost like the low-hanging
fruit that was easy to spot that was
like this is clearly what's happening
but it seems as if this sort of
funneling of gas is happening in every
galaxy all the time
but then you only see the after effects
of the merger because it's so
apparent right and that was like the key
thing that happened that you noticed
first we had some simulation friends as
well that simulated this happening and
they showed that 65
of all the stuff all the matter that's
currently found in supermassive black
holes in the universe got there because
of this funneling process in galaxies
not because of mergers so we've sort of
flipped the hypothesis on its head that
black holes grow by mergers and we're
like actually looks like the majority of
the time they're doing what you said at
the beginning right just happily taking
in is given to them
so we are in the blackhole laboratory
what you're looking at that's an analog
rotating black hole there are about 2000
liters of water in there if you follow
me here we have two walls which we can
open it was really thin
the picture of her majesty the queen
was just a vague shadow